i wish i had known that this too shall
pass
you feel bad right now you feel pissed
off you feel angry yes this too shall
pass
you feel great
you feel like you know all the answers
yeah yeah
you feel like that everybody finally
gets you and uh there you are yeah this
too
time is your ally
and if nothing else just wait just wait
just wait it out early american naval
commander john paul jones said
if fear is cultivated
it will become stronger if faith
is cultivated it will achieve mastery
fear
is whispered in our ears
and shout in our faces
faith must be fostered by the man or
woman you see every day in the mirror
the former forever snaps at our heels
and our synapses and delays our course
the latter can spur our boot heels to be
wandering
stimulate our creativity
and drive us forward
fear
or faith
which
will be
our master
three men found
that they could no longer sleep
because of their deep seated fears this
is a story i'm telling their lives were
in a state of status because of their
constant worries so they set out on a
pilgrimage to find
a wise man who lived high in the
mountains so high up above the tree line
that no vegetation grew no animals live
not even insects could be found so high
up in the mountains in that thin air and
when they reached his cave
the first of the three said help me wise
man for my fear has crippled me
what is your fear
said ask the wise man i fear death said
the pilgrim i wonder when it is going to
come for me ah death
said the wise man let me take away this
fear my friend
death
will not come to call until you
are ready for its embrace
know that
and you fear will go away well this
combat pilgrim's mind
and he feared death no longer
the wise man turned to the second
pilgrim and said what is it you fear
my friend
i fear my new neighbors
said the second pilgrim they are
strangers who observe holy days
different than mine they have way too
many kids
and they play music that sounds like
noise
ah strangers said the wise men
i will take away this fear my friend
return to your home
and make a cake
for your new neighbors
bring toys to their children
join them in their songs and learn their
ways and you will become familiar with
these neighbors
and your fear will go away
the second man saw the wisdom in these
simple instructions and knew he would no
longer fear
the family who were his neighbors the
wise man turned the last pilgrim and
asked of his fear o wise man
i fear spiders
when i try to sleep at night
i imagine spiders dropping from the
ceiling and crawling upon my flesh and i
cannot rest
ah
spiders said the wise man
no [ __ ] why do you think i live way up
here
your career as human beings is to stand
on the fulcrum between fear
and faith fear
at your back
faith in front of you which way will you
lean which way will you move if you're
as old as 29 you you have a different
set of of chops and and perspective you
have a different believe it or not
wisdom than you did when you were 24.
and i think about every five years
i went through some sort of process of
re-examining where i was in life you
know as a man
as well as an actor so it's a
never-ending process i think of
examining where you are
in life as a human being and then
transposing that so it's going to be
reflected in your work somehow you learn
something every time now oh yeah without
question sometimes you learn what not to
do in all honesty you know a mistake not
to make next time but uh what shortcuts
you can't take is anything missing in
terms of when you look at you know the
sort of craft of acting that you wish
you had you know oh
well it's always a battle against
self-consciousness it's hard to get past
the realization that you're pretending
to be somebody and people are looking at
you even if it's the crew i wish i had
more basic things at more tools i wish
i'd gone through more
classes i wish i had been forced to take
a dance class i wish i had forced to get
up and sing in front of people i wish i
had taken like my i wish i had gone to
that kind of like performance school
in which you have to get past the
self-consciousness of not being able to
do it well and still having to do it you
need to hear the most important message
thus far in the third millennium it's
not a statement it's but it's a request
it's not a bit of advice but it's it's a
plea
in fact it's a single four-letter word
help
help
and you will make a huge impact on the
life of the street the town the country
and our planet
if only one
out of four
of each hundred of you
choose to help on any given day in any
given cause incredible things will
happen in the world you live in help
publicly
help privately
help in your actions by recycling and
conserving and protecting
but help also in your attitude
help make sense where sense has gone
missing
help bring reason and respect to
discourse and debate
help science to solve and faith to
soothe
help law bring justice until justice is
commonplace
help
and you will
abolish apathy
the void which is so quickly filled by
ignorance
and evil your duty
is to help
without ceasing
the art you create
can glorify it
the science you pursue can prove its
value
the law you practice can pass on its
benefits
the faith you embrace
will make it the earthly manifestation
of your god so do it make peace
where it is precious
help plant trees
help embrace diversity and celebrate
differences in other words help
solve
every problem we face
help
and we will save the world